quiero multiplicar 9 por 10 a la 9 por
menos 2 por 10 a la menos 3 estamos
trabajando con potencias de 10 y puedes
poner pausa al vídeo puedes intentarlo
si gustas entonces lo primero que haré
para hacer esta multiplicación es
cambiar el orden de la multiplicación
así que vamos primero vamos a
multiplicar 9
x
- 2
y después esto lo vamos a multiplicar
por 10 a la 9
por 10 a la menos 3 ahora a que es igual
9 x menos 2 9 por 2 eso es igual a 18
entonces 9 x menos 2 es igual a menos 18
ya que es igual 19 por 10 a la menos 3 a
que es igual esto esto es igual
bueno en ambos números yo tengo la misma
base la base es el 10 entonces lo que
hago es poner esto lo vamos a
multiplicar por 10 a la 9 menos 3
entonces como tengo un mismo número
elevado a diferentes potencias tengo el
10 elevado a 9 y después tengo el 10
elevadora menos 3 así que yo aquí pongo
10 elevado a la 9
+ - 3
es decir tengo la base y voy a sumar las
potencias así que me queda menos 18 x
10 elevado a la sexta potencia y si
quieres saber qué número es este 10
elevado a la sexta potencia es igual a 1
seguido de 6 ceros entonces eso es un
millón así que menos 18 por un millón es
igual a menos 18 millones o podemos
simplemente poner menos 18 por 10 a la
sexta potencia o podríamos escribir
menos 18 y agregar 6 ceros 1 2 3 4 5 6
estos dos son iguales
simplemente son formas distintas de
escribir el mismo número